i was able to take home more in a year
than the ceo of mcdonald's ikea ford
motorola and yahoo combined as a kid in
his twenties
so for those of you who don't know me my
name is option rosie founder and ceo of
acquisition.com i have absolutely
nothing to sell you for those of the
mostly nation that's here what's up um
except for this book you can get on on
amazon for 99 cents um i i priced it
that way just because i just want
everyone to be able to have it um and
it's a fun side note for those of you
guys who are marketers in the audience
this book in the last three months has
sold 75 000 copies which is pretty wild
um and i have run no ads i have zero
funnels and i just made one post on
instagram which i don't have a big
instagram um
and that was it and so i think that as
much as we like to talk about all of the
things that come to marketing and making
offers and direct response and all of
that jazz the biggest companies in the
world are so big because they build
products that people
want to buy and want to tell their
friends about
and if you make your product so good
that people can't help but tell other
people about it build the fortunes that
you desire and so um i say this just as
a reminder because you know i think a
lot of people could tell that when i
wrote the book it was out of love it's
99 cents and i think that if we can if
we can work from that place you will
create things that are more magical than
all the people who are trying to create
things out of scarcity only to make a
buck
and so anyways just as a side note so
you guys want to hear something totally
insane like completely out there wild i
was able to take home more in a year
than the ceo of mcdonald's
ikea
ford
motorola
and
yahoo combined
as a kid in his 20s that equated to 1.2
million dollars per month in dividends
for nearly the last half decade honestly
no one is more surprised than i am
about that and so me expressing this
fact early on in this presentation in
some people will create envy um it'll
create anger in other people it'll
create skepticism in most
and confusion in old folks and hopefully
it should inspire a select few
and so if that was you then you are the
people that i'm making this presentation
for all right
because i know exactly
where you're at um because i have been
there and i'll walk you through that so
i was um i was talking at an event not
that long ago and they had like levels
to entrepreneurship and level seven was
what they called me which was like the
highest level which is kind of silly for
me because i
you'll see in a second why just a couple
observations for everyone kind of like
from outside looking in that may be
valuable for you
the first one is that everyone wants you
to do well
just not better than them
and i think that's something that we can
all recognize like
some of you probably have experienced
that
other you will experience that if you
have people rooting for you as an
underdog sometimes that will change as
you become more successful
second
accept that no one actually wants you to
be rich except for you
and so it's only going to be up to you
to get there and the nice thing about
success habits and wealth and business
is that even if you don't deserve it in
terms of your character etc if you still
do the actions success does not care so
success is colorblind success only cares
about the work that is done
third point that i've kind of found in
my in my time
money only solves money problems and
then you're left with problems that
money can't solve and so i know a lot of
you um maybe maybe in a situation where
like another you know more money feels
like it will solve all your problems and
i can tell you um it won't it'll just
solve the ones that money can solve
you'll realize which is uh point four is
that you don't actually arrive ever
you just enter a new club as the
smallest member and so in the building
that i live in it's almost exclusively
eight nine and ten figure entrepreneurs
so eight is ten million nine is 100
million and ten is a billion the guy who
lives directly above me so literally the
unit directly above me he actually owns
the entire building and last year he did
3.8 billion in sales top line he took
home 930 million dollars in income
and so all that ends up happening is you
you just get into a new new club as the
smallest member there's just levels to
the game
and um i'll just leave you with this one
last thing for those of you uh who see
what i see on the internet world and the
instagram flexes is that everyone talks
about the laptop lifestyle having a
business that spits out cash flow for
you passive income blah blah blah this
last year i did almost nothing
work wise and our businesses generate a
tremendous amount of cash flow i can
tell you that i was very miserable i
think that we need as a community to
make work cool again because we kind of
i see it all over the place especially
in the entrepreneurship of demonizing
the grind demonizing
the hustle demonizing putting the hours
in um and saying that like if your
business requires you that it's not a
real business and i think that it's a
load of bs because after having now
exited the business
uh at multiple businesses now i can tell
you it's not fun and i feel like what my
my end result of this entire process for
me is that i sought out freedom thinking
that freedom and i didn't i had all my
time
when what i should have been pursuing
was options
and so if you enjoy the work you do
you have arrived and so i can tell you
right now and what i'm doing in 2022 is
basically repositioning myself to get
back 100 into the grind because i choose
to and so anyways i wanted to just give
you guys that because i know a lot of
people are in different different places
but i just wanted to share some things
that i wish i had heard earlier on
so who wants to hear about some stuff
that can shortcut your path to material
success so you can ponder the purpose of
achieving it to begin with let's rock
and roll all right so here's a quick
framework that i have for making offers
all right and the reason that we're
gonna focus on offers is because i
believe that they are the fastest
shortcut to material success in a
business if i'm going to take a business
over i'm going to take a a chunk of a
business as an investor the first thing
i'm going to do is look at the offer
stack which is what are the things what
are the sequence of offers we're going
to make to the customers and prospects
over their journey with the business now
there's a lot of things that i cover in
the book and i like i said earlier i
could have covered every single one of
them but instead i'm going to cover four
main ones okay so these are the main
things that i look at in the business
and some of the issues that most
business owners deal with one is the
commodity problem so the goal is to
de-commoditize it the second is making
sure that we're actually targeting the
right avatar who we think is going to be
able to generate us the most long-term
lifetime revenue all right the third is
that we're going to make sure that we
can charge a premium price for the the
services and products that we sell and
then fourth i'm going to cover the value
equation all right because it's probably
the biggest takeaway of the book and it
is probably it is the concept that the
book is based around all right scarcity
urgency bonuses guarantees and naming
are all things that will enhance the
effectiveness of your offer um and i'll
tell you at the end some some easy
resources that i can i can give you guys
for those all right cool so we're going
to cover these four and so let's rock
and roll
so here's the problem right now if your
ads are not converting well so clicks
and opt-ins uh and or your sales team
has trouble scaling so it means it takes
too long to ramp up new new reps um then
adjusting your offer is usually the
issue it's usually the core problem that
most people don't see all right and so
to catch fish you need bait we're in
offer all right an offer is the starting
port of
data transfer customer
providing them in exchange for their
money that is what an offer is the
reason i define is because it's good to
have shared terminology an offer is
going to be the number one driver of
success of any campaign and i'll prove
it to you in a second all right so what
does it actually do it will allow you to
sell in a vacuum or a category of one
and forces customers to make a
values-based decision instead of a
price-based decision all right i'm gonna
say that again it will force your
customers if done successfully to make a
values-based decision instead of a price
based decision all right if someone
makes a price-based decision means they
hold up two things they say these are
close enough i will make a decision
based on the price and i will choose the
cheaper one because these two are
comparable
if i make a values-based decision i say
this is the only thing i have nothing
else i can compare it to and therefore i
must accept the price that is being
charged if i deem the value sufficient
all right
and so the goal is to decommoditize the
offer that we are selling so that we can
sell in a category of one and you can do
this in any type of business that you
have
and so when you do this successfully
you will increase the click-through
rates on your offers on any platform
you're doing whether it's cold outbound
whether it's whether it's cold emails
whether it's ads whether it's earned
media whether it's to your list it
doesn't matter where you're presenting
the actual offer where those that offer
sits with eyeballs wherever the eyeballs
are if you make a de-commoditized offer
that is value-based rather than price
driven you will increase the number of
clicks that you get you'll increase the
percentage of those clicks that convert
and you'll increase the price at which
those people purchase all right and so
the simple translation for that for
those who are or hopefully
not poured out of your mind with the the
concept or with the the marketing jargon
is you get more leads you get more sales
at higher prices and each of those
multiply so if you get two extra leads
2x the conversion on those leads which
is now a 4x and then you can increase
your price by 2x that is an 8x increase
in business
that is why the offer is so important
and so strong so i'm going to give you
guys a real life example so b2c weight
loss right now is 99 a month if we're
going to try and sell that all right for
99 a month i could not do it all right i
failed miserably and so what i had to do
when i was trying to i couldn't even
give this away for free we transformed
this offer into a free six-week
challenge by doing that what ended up
happening is we changed a not even
break-even offer to getting 30 to 1
returns
30 to 1 returns on our advertising all
right the second example i want to give
you i'm going to walk you through this
one live together
is a 1500 per month retainer offer uh
one of our software companies that we
sold on allen we dealt with a lot of
brick-and-mortar agencies so people who
would sell to chiropractors people who
would sell to whatever right a lot of
times they had an issue where they were
getting commoditized right everyone had
more or less the same offer and so they
would say hey pay me every month and
either you get results or you don't get
results and the average agency who was
there would get about point five to one
return on their ad spend in their first
30 days so if they spend a thousand
bucks they would make 500 on average and
then the next month they would make a
thousand and so forth right so they kind
of broke even or lost a little in the
front end and then they continued on the
back end but what we were able to do is
actually 22x the increase on average of
the return on ad spend by simply
changing the offer is that cool so right
now if you could 22x the difference that
you got and it did the same thing in the
first one same thing on the second we're
talking 20x 30x increase the return on
ad spend would that be cool for you guys
this is what happened before with the
agency offer okay if you look here i
have this chart and this is these are
the actual numbers so when the guys were
spending ten thousand dollars a month
they reached 300 000 people the response
rate was point zero zero zero one three
right the number of appointments that
booked was 40. the show rate was 75
appointments showed 30 you know closing
percentage was sixteen percent
cleanliness was five price was a
thousand bucks right so they'd make five
thousand dollars off ten thousand these
were the real numbers okay
now when we introduced the new grand
slam offer and the new offer that we
gave them was pay us one time
and we will work all of your leads for
you and then you only pay us a gun after
this first payment
after someone shows up
so only pay us when someone shows up
after you sign up with us that's it you
pay me once today i set everything up
and from that point going forward you
never have to pay me again unless
someone walks in your so check out the
difference here so the advertising spend
was equivalent between you know day one
it says ten thousand ten thousand right
impressions are the same because you
know ads still cost the same amount but
here's what's crazy
two and a half x increase in response
rate
okay
two and a half x but that's just step
one now the changing result is we got
from forty appointments to a hundred
appointments for that ten thousand
dollars of ad spend show rate was the
same nothing changed there but now we
have 75 people showed up rather than 30.
and here's the next crazy part is that
rather than closing 16 which is what
they were doing with their commoditized
offer at a lower price they were now
closing 37
that's 2.3 x all right so more people
were now buying more
okay and so now i look at the difference
in appointments closed you have five
appointments closed versus 28 that's the
result
and here's what's even crazier they were
closing 16 of the thousand price point
but with the new offer the grand slam
offer they were closing that at four
times the price
four times the price and so this was the
end result for that same ten thousand
dollars in ad spend went used to get
them five clients at five thousand
dollars a month and there's their five
thousand dollars instead now they got 28
customers at 4 000 up front with a
continuity program that had what i call
an implied guarantee which i won't be
able to get into today but basically any
kind of performance offer that you can
make is always an implied guarantee and
so they would make a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars simply by changing the
offer which is a 22.4x increase in cash
collected upfront and that doesn't even
include the lifetime value on the back
end so you guys getting how powerful
this is the difference between 0.5 and
11.2 they didn't even change the
creative they just changed the offer
they didn't change their funnels they
didn't change their nurture sequences
they changed any of that stuff they just
changed what they were offering to the
marketplace all right so right now can
you think about in your business how if
you could change that core thing how
different the outcomes could be
cool does everyone feel good about that
in terms of understanding why this is so
important and why the goal should to not
be a commodity but actually sell in a
category of one with an offer that's so
good that people feel stupid saying no
does that make sense that is why this is
so important because otherwise you're
gonna be price compared you're gonna
you're gonna have lower conversions
you're gonna have lower people show up
you're gonna be able to only sell at low
prices and you're ultimately just gonna
be like everybody else and everybody
else is broke so don't be like them so
step number two is making sure that we
find the right market
all right so um
this is kind of an interesting concept
so i was at a uh and if the picture is
blurry it's because my picture's
actually blurry and i couldn't find a
sharp one
um so i went to this mastermind um and
in the room the the entire group was
doing um actually was 600 million in top
line revenue so the highest guy was
doing 250 million smallest guy was doing
seven second smallest guy at the time
was doing 35 all right um and everybody
else was in between and so i was sitting
there and you know i was watching these
guys do their presentations and i just i
was left with this feeling where i was
like
are these guys making more money i was
like i couldn't get it like i i was just
like i was losing my mind to try to
figure this out right
and then it dawned on me after i was
just like going on these blocks i was
like they're just going after better
markets
that's all like that was it like it
wasn't they were better at sales wasn't
there better at marketing it wasn't like
they were better at fulfillment i was
like i know that we're nailing these
things because when i was talking to
them i didn't feel like they i lacked
something
it was just because they were going
after the right market all right and so
there you go it's almost like i made
this presentation and that was the
conclusion they pick better markets and
so what i want to do is because this is
probably the number one question i get
from people who are newer in the
entrepreneurial space um and so here's
the quick answer that i give most people
if you're trying to figure out who
you're going to serve right in your
earlier on in your journey
the way to pick that person is select
the after you can provide the most
values period so if you have like two or
three people you're trying to decide
between
pick the guy you can provide the most
value to that's the game number two
the medium answer
you want to make sure that you pick a
single avatar so that you can productize
your service and provide that value with
low operational drag so let me give you
an example so if you were to help one
chiropractor do something right and
generate leads or whatever
then you would probably it would take
you a lot of work to get that first guy
going right
but if you had a hundred chiropractors
your 100th chiropractor you probably
have a lot of that stuff pre-built and
pre-made right which means the amount of
time and effort that it would take you
to do that hundredth one is very low and
on top of that through that hundred
iterations you probably get better and
better and better and so here's what
happens the value that you provide
actually increases and the cost to you
actually decreases which means there's a
big discrepancy between what that person
is now getting and how much it costs you
and we call that profit which is the
point right and so the reason that we
niche down when we're picking our
markets is so that we can ultimately
make more money and i don't have this uh
example in the presentation but right
now if i were to say hey guys i have a
time management product right and uh
if i if i was selling it and you go to
barnes and nobles whatever you probably
find it for 19 bucks right it's just
time management cool
now if i were to say hey
same product but now it's time
management for sales people
can you all of a sudden imagine that
product being like a 99 product
like oh okay i can imagine that being a
99 product all right
now let's niche down a little further
and say well of the people that could
you know make the most money with time
sales people definitely will will make
more money with save time but what about
outbound sales people we can make it
even more specific and talk about their
pain points etc and so we now make it an
outbound sales rep time management
course or book right and now this is
probably like can you imagine that it's
more probably more like a 500 product
right so you're an outbound sales rep
time management for outbound sales reps
ah
so what if we ditch down even further
and we said
um outbound
power tools and gardening sales reps
time management
all of a sudden this product goes from
500 to a 2000 product right now here's
what's crazy about this
the product remains virtually unchanged
the only thing we did is we defined who
the avatar was and we got narrower and
narrower and narrower and so right now
if you're thinking like the goal is that
that prospect when they read your
persuasion they read your copy the goal
is not for them for
for them to understand
what you are writing the goal is for
them to feel understood and that is the
goal of great persuasion is that they
feel understood
that's the point and so the better we
can articulate their problems and their
reality to them the more they will be
willing to purchase our product right
and the more what we want them to feel
is this is just for me
and that's the goal right and so when
we're picking that market right
let's go back to our presentation this
is my live speech answer which is what
you guys are gonna get so i give you the
quick answer which is provide go go pick
the guy you can provide the most value
to the medium answer is
zero in on that niche and go really hard
on it so that you can eventually
productize your service and decrease
your operational drag but here's my live
speech answer all right so right now
let's pretend we're we're in class right
and there's a marketing professor that's
um that's in front of the in front of in
front of in front of us right and he
says everybody here has now been gifted
a hot dog stand and you are now forced
to be in the hot dog stand business if
you had one competitive advantage for
your hot dog stand what would it be well
i'll tell you in this uh and i think
this may actually be a real story so i'm
not sure and so in the classroom all
these people started starting shouting
out all those things right you know
better ingredients
right and after everyone died down he
said
the secret is that you want a starving
crowd
because when the football game lets out
at 3 o'clock in the afternoon and
everyone's starving and drunk
you want to be the guy on the hot dog
stand in the corner and you could have
the worst hot dogs that were wildly
overpriced and you would still sell out
because when you have a starving crowd
when the supply demand curve is in your
favor it's hard to not make money and
not make lots of it okay and so when
we're looking at the market
these are the four attributes that i
look for when i'm looking to pursue a
market okay
you can write these down number one is i
want them to not just desire but be in
desperate need of the solution that i
have all right i don't want people who
are merely aroused i want people who are
ravenous for a solution number two they
must have the ability to purchase the
product that i want at the price that i
want to charge
number three they must be easy to target
i can't target them i can't put my offer
in front of them i'll ultimately not be
able to reach them and sell and then
number four i want to make sure that
it's growing market all right so let's
dive in
so one of the sayings that i have in my
sales team is the pain is the pitch
right and like i said earlier the point
of good writing is for the reader to
understand the point of good persuasion
is for the prospect to feel understood
all right and so the goal here is that
we want them to feel
understood in the copy which is why
niching down is so important right it's
very difficult to make someone feel
unique and singled out if you're talking
to the masses right which is why it's so
amazing that some of these mass market
brands that do exist but most of them
start small and then continue to scale
in adjacent markets all right so we want
to make sure that they're in desperate
need
number two so a friend of mine um had a
really good process for improving
people's resumes so they could get more
job interviews like he had a really
dialed in process and he looked at these
four things and he was like well this is
i think this will absolutely crush and
as you guys might even imagine
is
improving people's resumes so they can
get more interviews it actually tanked
and the reason was
the p it was a growing market it was
easy to find the unemployed people they
were in desperate pain but they had no
money right and so he had a really hard
time charging the amount that he wanted
for the service that he had right and so
we got to make sure that whatever market
you're zeroing in on they can afford you
right and the thing is is there is a
market out there that is in desperate
need of a solution that you have find
them right and they will pay you what
you're worth
life's too short to deal with people who
don't appreciate you all right
so
number three
this one is very tactical right but if
you're trying to sell to you know rich
doctors and your ads or your offers are
only being displayed to nurses
it's going to fall on deaf ears no
matter how good the offer is no matter
how good your funnels are no matter how
good your sales team is and how great
the product is you're just not reaching
it right and so if your people are not
aggregated somewhere in associations
groups list channels etc then just don't
pick it because at the end of the day
like business is hard enough on its own
you might as well just make the things
have as many tailwinds behind you as you
possibly can because the thing is it's
ultimately our choice right whatever
business or marketplace we choose to get
into it's our choice so i might as well
pick one that's going to be easy to work
on this is a little bit of a tactical
point but this is just through my
experience of dealing with lots of
companies and having owned and scaled
lots of companies it's much easier to
deal with ones that are easy to target
all right
and so here's the fourth one this
probably one of my favorite stories so
warren buffett was doing an interview
and he was talking about uh his best
friend at columbia and so this is before
he was more above it he was just a nerdy
kid who liked finance at this point
right
and he said there was a young gentleman
who he admired a lot who he thought was
you know incredibly sharp had tremendous
work ethic high integrity um and he was
somebody that he was proud to be
associated with and ultimately when they
graduated columbia they split they split
ways right one person went into
steel and then he obviously went into
his partnership that eventually became
bertrand right and what's interesting is
he said when he looks back on his life
one of the most important lessons that
happened is that that individual that
man that friend of his he said he
achieved some material success he said
but nothing you know nothing really
remarkable and he said that that lesson
from that man was singular in its
importance because what it taught him
was it is far more important what boat
you are in rather than how hard you row
it is far more important
what vote you are in rather than how
hard you row
and so a lot of you a lot of us as
entrepreneurs we pick these huge
challenges that and we're just rowing
and growing and growing and trying to
outpace the current that's going in the
other direction and so there's an old vc
saying that's a venture capital saying
where it's great entrepreneur
in bad market market wins
bad entrepreneur
in great market market wins
right and so the point is is that the
market matters more than anything when
people actually are investing in
businesses they actually look they're
like what markets do i want to get
exposed to because they know that even
if we're mediocre and the market
quadruples then we will quadruple even
if we're average and so we might as well
have the tailwind and i'll tell you one
final story about this so good friend of
mine lloyd um really sharp entrepreneur
he had a software company and uh it grew
and then all of a sudden it started
stagnating right and this is probably
like six or seven years ago
and he's and and for six or seven years
i saw him really struggle right to grow
the business and he was uh he was in the
newspaper business right
and so he was selling an ad product to
newspapers
and one time we're having dinner he's
like dude i just don't know what's going
on he's like my offer is a rep share
model like it's they only get you know i
only get paid if they get if they make
money uh you know we've got a great
outbound team we got a great sales team
like i just i don't know what the
problem is and i'm looking at him from
across the table and i was like you
serious he was like yeah i was like dude
you're selling newspapers they're dying
they're losing 25 per year compounding
25 newspapers about a business every
year and they have for the last eight
years and so that's how big the market
was that's how much the market was
shrinking annually compounded against
him and this is probably of the four
factors the biggest one that we have to
look at when we're trying to pick our
market is we might as well pick the
right boat one that has a tide that's
behind it with a heavy you know with a
good wind going in the right direction
because no matter what business is gonna
be hard we might as well have one that's
going in the right direction so those
are the four components of picking the
right market is that useful for you guys
in terms of making sure that you're
niching down
picking people who have have pain
have purchasing power are easy to find
and are growing all right we want a
market that is growing there's more of
them every year right if you're getting
into sil you know silver sneakers and
retirement homes there are 10 000 people
retiring a day and there's not nearly 10
000 units of retirement homes available
right which means that that's probably
going to be something that if you're in
that space you're going to make a lot of
money simply because of supply demand
we'd rather have those chips stacked in
our favor so i want to play a money game
and this is not in the book so you guys
pay attention to this one this is
actually my favorite money games of all
time okay
so
let's say that this is your business you
can see the stats on the left there and
hopefully it's clear for you um let's
say that you have a business that gets
30 new clients a month let's say your
churn meaning the percentage of
customers that leave every month where
active is 33 that means that the average
customer stays for three months okay
let's say the price of your service
whatever it is a hundred dollars a month
i'm using simple math here okay and so
that would mean that your total number
of clients that you can actively manage
is 100 because every time you sign up 30
30 more leave and it's just around and
around and it maintains at 100. all
right well let's say your net margins
are 20
so that would mean that your revenue is
10 thousand dollars a month and your
profit's 2 000
all right is everyone with me so far
everyone good with this okay
so let's say we rub we rub a magic water
bottle right and this magic water bottle
is a very specific niche water bottle
because this niche water water bottle
creates a niched genie okay and so the
little niche genie comes out of the the
the bottle and says i am a business gin
you're like oh wow this guy's intense
right he says i can double one aspect of
your business
and you must pick which of the three you
wish me to double right so it's a very
niche genie very particular about his
about his wish selection but you know
we're like hey i'll take a wish if i can
get one right and so these are the three
doors that he offers us okay
choice number one is that he says i can
double the number of new customers that
you get every month so that 30 number
turns to 60 new customers a month so i
can do that that's option one
option two
i can double the price of your products
or services and everything else stays
the same
that's option two
say okay cool option three
i can double the number of purchases per
customer which means that people go from
staying for three months to staying for
six months okay so our trend gets cut in
half which of the wishes would you wish
for from our business genie fyi no
matter what you're going to make more
money because we got a business genius
we kind of lucked out there right so if
you were to double the number of new
customers what would happen is
everything would double so you'd go from
10 10 uh 10 000 a month to 20 a month
your profit would go and your you know
margin stays the same twenty percent so
now you go from two thousand dollars a
month to four thousand dollars a month
in profit right twenty percent twenty
thousand is four grand from twenty
percent of ten thousand which is two
grand all right so two grand goes to
four grand you've now doubled your
profit that was door number one
door number three
if you double the number of purchases
you actually make a little bit more than
twice the profit and here's why
if you now are acquiring the same number
of customers right but they're staying
twice as long right on your on your
recurring basis
but the margin stays the same
the difference is that the the cost of
acquisition that you are now saving and
not you'll get the same top-line revenue
as as version one because that customer
is now worth twice as much to you
but you only have to spend this this
amount of amount of money that it costs
you to acquire
that same 30. right so now you're you're
still spending the same amount you're
still acquiring 30 customers but now
they're worth twice as much right and so
by doing that you actually make a little
bit more than twice the profit door one
is the quote worst door
the second runner-up or the first
runner-up rather is
doubling the number of purchases or
decreasing turn in half and as you can
imagine the best choice was choice two
which is doubling the price of your
product or service and here's why this
is so crazy
so i'm gonna walk you through this i'm
gonna use my hands all right
so if we were at ten thousand dollars a
month with a twenty percent margin that
means we're making two thousand
now all of a sudden we doubled our price
now we're at twenty thousand dollars a
month but we changed nothing
about what we were selling and providing
which means that additional ten thousand
dollars a month
is pure profit
which means we took our our profit from
two thousand dollars a month to twelve
thousand dollars a month
which means we six x our income
six x
people talk about making 20 increases
this is a 600 increase
that my friends
is the power of price which i wanted to
use that story to introduce the pricing
section which is why it's called charge
what it's worth and right now many of
you are undercharging and ultimately
under providing value because you are
not charging the right amount of money
all right so i'm going to give you a few
frameworks that have served me well here
so this one is called the price to value
discrepancy the goal of any business is
to have a private
uh you know a dollar for something
i want you to get ten dollars worth of
value right which is why you want to
continue to do business because every
time you give me a dollar if you get ten
dollars of perceived value back you're
going to want to do that trade as much
you know as many times you possibly can
right right so many of you would
probably pay more than you currently do
for your netflix subscription you might
pay 20 a month if they raised it and be
okay with it they might pay 30 a month
but the amount of access they leave
there is the customer surplus all right
and so you can see there there's the
value and the price and we always want
to make sure that the price is below the
value here's what happens with most
businesses though most businesses charge
their uh
their price is actually above their
value which is why they never get repeat
customers because their product is [ __ ]
right if you charge at your value
someone will purchase they won't be
negative they won't be positive they'll
be moved right and so there's two real
options here we can either increase that
discrepancy by lowering our price so
let's say our value is fixed right if we
lower our price we have a discrepancy
right the other option is to raise our
value
right and i can tell you one of those is
gonna make you a lot more money all
right and i'm sure you already know
which one it is which is increasing your
value all right so
this is what most people do and why you
should charge so much that it hurts
most business owners are not competing
on price or value in fact they're not
actually competing on anything at all
their pricing process typically looks
something like this and this may be some
of your guys
process you look at the marketplace you
see without what everyone else is
offering you take the average you go
slightly below to remain competitive
provide what the competition's offering
with a little bit more and then end up
with a value proposition of a little
more for a little less it's a losing
proposition
you're not going to win that way and so
what i want to do is introduce you to a
very different framework to think
through this all right and this is
called the
virtuous versus vicious cycle of price
all right
so
this is what happens when you raise your
prices all right so if you have any type
of business where someone is required to
do something right like onyx business
right you guys are required to do
something uh in order to succeed right
we have to work
now if we raise our prices
this is what happens
if you raise your price you increase the
emotional investment of the person if
you pay ten thousand dollars for a book
versus a dollar for a book what do you
think the likelihood is that you're
going to read and finish the book if you
pay ten thousand dollars for very high
so same book because we've increased the
price we increase the likelihood the
person actually does it which if we're
saying that we're trying to help people
then it is ethically
our prerogative
to get them as emotionally invested as
possible which means we should use one
of the tools we have in our availability
which is price
the second is that if you buy a ten
thousand dollar book versus a one dollar
book what is your perceived value
you will probably believe that the value
is going to be far superior even if you
change nothing i'll give you a quick
story on this so
right now uh they did a uh they did a
research study with this where they had
um
tasters drink wine all right and so they
gave them three wines they had cheap
wine
a mid-tier wine and a high tier wine and
they told them the price and everything
um on the bottles and they had them try
them and they had them rank them right
and they could see the prices
and so unsurprisingly they rank the best
one the best the middle one the middle
and the cheapest one the the worst right
but here was what's crazy
all three bottles had the exact same one
so in a very real way
price confers value to the product or
service that you provide
the reason the louis vuitton perch uh
purse means more to you is partially
because it is so expensive
because it costs us so much time and
effort to save the money to make the
purchase it partially gets it it
imprints that value onto the product so
why not use that to our advantage and
especially if we're going to make a lot
more money doing it
the third piece is that if someone's
more emotionally invested and they
perceive it as more valuable they're
going to get better results if the price
is higher right
the demandingness of the customer and
some of you guys will probably know this
have you guys noticed that your cheapest
customers are the worst people and the
ones who pay you the most are the
easiest to deal with
right
so when you raise your price you get
more of the good people and fewer of the
bad people right hey 50 a month you
should be on call for me 24 hours a day
you're like
i don't know
if i like you more than my wife and then
finally and this is one of the key
points that drives me uh drives the
decision home for me is that the revenue
for fulfillment per customer so if you
triple you know the profit that you make
on a sale then you have three times the
amount of resources compared to your
competitor to provide the value that you
promised
and ultimately in doing that you
actually provide a better product and so
that is why this is called a virtuous
cycle because the more you increase
price the more you increase their
emotional investment the more you
increase their perceived value of the
product that you're giving the better
results they get the less demanding they
are which is the less operational drag
you have to deal with and ultimately the
better product that you'll be able to
fill because you can keep your promises
because you have profit left over
all right and this is what also
people care less they they value it less
they get worse results they're more
demanding and you have even less
resources left over to hire amazing
people to give an amazing experience
because there's so little profit left
over right that would be a vicious cycle
and then for you as the business owner
so that was just from the client's
perspective but for you as a business
owner if you increase your price you
increase your profit
if you increase your price you increase
your perceived value of self because who
here would rather sell a hundred
thousand dollar thing than a ten
thousand it's a ten dollar thing
right your own perceived value of what i
am worth because of the value i know i
can provide goes up all right and your
perception of impact because i'll be
honest with you like business can get
hard but if you're not reminded
constantly on a daily basis of the good
you are doing the impact you're making
the customers that you have that are
seeing amazing results and success from
whatever experience or transformation
you provide
if you don't have that
you're going to be lost eventually
you're going to burn out but if you do
have that because you raised your price
and you had profit to give and reinvest
in the business and create amazing
experiences then you'll feel better
about it right your service level will
go up
and then finally and this is a key one
if you have a sales team or if you're
the sales team because of the emotional
investment perceived value results uh
and and the amount of extra profit you
left over for the experience that you
want to build you will be convicted that
you can fulfill the promises that you
make and the number one thing that
converts prospects into customers is
their belief that you will actually be
able to help them and that belief starts
with you because at the end of the day
sales is a transference of conviction
from you to them through a bridge of
trust right that is the point that is
how it works and so if you don't have
the conviction to start with even if you
have the trust you'll never be able to
transfer it because you don't actually
have the conviction yourself and so when
we think in this way we realize that
raising our prices having increased
profits is not only a good thing to do
business-wise but also the ethical thing
to do if you want to provide your
customers with the true result that you
promise them all right and so the goal
here which i wrote here on the right is
to be so much higher that a consumer
thinks to themselves this is so much
more expensive there must be something
entirely different going on here and it
forces them to pull you out of that
commoditized category into a category
one so they consider you on your own and
your own merits of the offer itself and
then make a values-based decision you
guys digging this is this cool
interesting
sweet okay that was framework number
three which is charging what it's worth
i'm doing okay on time so i'll we're
going in the into the fourth fourth
fourth quarter okay which is the value
equation and this is the concept that
this book is really um centered around
all right which is this value equation
so i'll tell you a quick story so um
i i did this uh i did this presentation
um this was a two-day event that we held
and this is actually a fulfillment event
this is not a sales event um for for my
company and so every single picture
every single head that you see in this
in this room paid 42 thousand dollars to
be there
and if you're keeping track from home
and you're trying to count 42 000 start
at the bottom and go to the left
there's 700 people all right it's a very
big room it's very deep
and um i remember the morning after i
felt kind of hung over because i'd been
speaking for two straight days
and my dad called me up and he sounded
really concerned so i like rolled out of
bed and i was like hold on i like put a
hoodie on and start walking the hallway
he was like hey i thought i thought that
event that you had was only for your
highest level kites and i was like yeah
it was he's like no i mean the 42 000
people and i was like
yeah it was
he was like
you had
so many people there how could how could
you have
them all pay 42 000 to be there he's
like do they do they know you're
charging them that much money this is my
dad right and i was like
yeah they're aware that i'm charging i'm
not magically siphoning money from their
bank accounts like they're aware
he's like i mean i hope what you're
selling is worth it it's my father my
own father sells me this right
and so you know as much as that might
have stung in the moment right um i
realized that it was just a lack of
understanding he didn't get how value
worked and so i said well let me walk
you through an example
i said if right now because he he is a
small business and i said hey if if i
were able to increase your top line
revenue by 239 000 a year
would you pay me 42 grand he's like well
it depends he said what would i have to
do
and i was like well
uh you'd have to work 15 hours a week
more to to do the system it was like
okay he said how do how do i how like
like do i know is it guaranteed like how
do i know that that's what i'm gonna get
and i was like that's just the average
which means half of people do better
than if you think you were above average
then you did more than that he's like
okay
um
and how long would it take for me to for
me to get that result
and i was like 11 months on average
and he was like it would take me 11
months
that's the
um
and i was like yeah he's like yeah then
i would pay 42 000 a year for that and i
was like exactly and that's why they do
too
and so ultimately that is a premium
price experience that i have lived
through all right so that's 700 people
at our highest level in our gym word
business which is a licensing business
we paid that as 28 million a year just
from the highest level okay
and the reason that that is important
is that you can absolutely charge a very
large amount of money
if
you can provide value for an access of
that who here would pay you know forty
thousand dollars to make an extra two
hundred and forty thousand dollars on
average would you guys do that if those
are the terms yes and that is why these
people do too and so if you want to
raise your prices you must ultimately
raise your value and the reason i part
of the reason i wrote this book was
because i hear the term value thrown
around in the entrepreneurial community
all day long provide value give value
blah blah blah right
but no one actually defines what the
term means so this is my best effort at
defining it so there's four variables to
the value equation all right and so it's
a fraction you've got a numerator and a
denominator you guys can remember from
grade school all right the numerator
numerators the top denominators the
bottom all right and so if you're trying
to make a bigger value or bigger number
here the goal is to maximize the top and
minimize the bottom right right so let's
go through the first one
the first one here
is oops there we go dream outcome all
right so the dream outcome is simply to
demonstrate that the person must
desperately desire what it is you're
selling sometimes you guys are selling
things that no one actually wants which
is why no one buys the dream outcome
doesn't even match right you're trying
to sell you know automation to doctors
or something like they don't care
whatever right
you don't actually want to be selling
ice to eskimos because they're like i
got plenty of ice and i don't value it
right so as much as that saying is cute
it's also not very business that right
and so dream outcome is uh is number one
and so the reason that this is so
important is that if let's say for men
for example most men get more status
from having money than being you know
thin right and so if i were to survey
guys would you rather be a millionaire
would you rather be thin most guys would
choose millionaires right right and so
that means that as a category overall
men will value money more than their
appearances which is why
you know you see
i won't even get into this more than
that but hopefully you should understand
that which is why the entire category of
making making people make more money
return on investment et cetera has
higher price tags in general
okay and that is what differentiates so
if you have two different things one is
helps guys make more money and the other
one helps them lose weight the one that
helps guys make more money in general
will be priced higher now
what happens if you have two products
that are in the same category and one
sells for fifty thousand and one sells
for five dollars well the reason that
you have the other uh that you have that
price discrepancy due to two things in
the same dream outcome is the other
three variables right how come
liposuction is fifty thousand dollars
and a weight loss ebook is five bucks
even though the dream outcome of weight
loss is the same right right so that
brings us to the second part of this
equation all right which is perceived
likelihood of achievement if i'm buying
a five dollar ebook what do i really
think my perceived likelihood is that
i'm actually going to lose weight and
look amazingly the guy in the cup for
five bucks for an e-book probably pretty
low i might even not even read it right
how many of you check my email right now
on the flip side if i pay 50 000 for
liposuction what's the likelihood that i
think it's actually going to happen
really freaking high right
so let me give you a different version
to illustrate this concept of how
increasing the perceived likelihood of
achievement actually increases the value
you can charge all right this is the
front end so let's say in that
liposuction example you've got two
doctors you can pick from you got a
doctor who's fresh out of medical school
he's never cut into a person you're
gonna be his first patient
and then the second doctor has done this
procedure specifically for you ten
thousand times for people just like you
which guy are you gonna pick
doctor two with ten thousand successful
surgeries or doctor one with zero
this guy not only that you would
probably be way more willing to pay way
more money for this guy even though the
actual surgery dream outcome time under
the knife would remain the same and that
is because you we confer value based on
our perception of the likelihood that
the person is going to provide us the
service that we have i had a different
price point for my business when i had
100 testimonials versus 2 000
because that was the that was so very by
the way if any of you guys ever have to
raise your prices did you get better and
better over time you said that was the
100 testimonial price because there was
lower perceived likelihood of
achievement now i've got 2 000 you know
it's going to work the goal of the top
is to increase it now most starter
marketers only focus on the top half of
the equation but when you look at the
biggest businesses in the world
they actually put all their attention on
the bottom half which is actually where
the competitive moat from operations
occurs okay so the third variable here
is time delay which is how long between
when i purchase and when i get so if i
were to click a button on the internet
for a weight loss product and all of a
sudden i pulled my shirt up and i had a
six pack imagine how infinitely valuable
that product would be and to give a
different twist on the example imagine i
had a marketing agency and i signed
someone up and most are
competing against saying oh it's going
to take to use
you know do all these things whereas the
one that i just signed up for the agency
that i created as soon as i sign the
paper my phone rings the qualified
appointment and they say hey i just saw
your ad imagine the difference in value
the difference there even though that
might have happened 60 days later in the
in the second example is time delay fast
beats free the easiest way to provide
value in any marketplace is look what
everyone else is doing and do it at half
the time
all right so that is an element and the
third component of value the goal is to
decrease it and then finally
we have effort and sacrifice right and
effort and sacrifice are two sides at
the same point effort is things that you
must now start doing that you do not
want to do that you must do as a result
of a purchase
sacrifice are things that you now must
stop doing that you
like doing that you can no longer do as
a result of a purchase so for example
i'll use weight loss because we've been
keeping it consistent um if if i have to
start waking up earlier in the morning
then that is effort if i have to endure
being sore that is effort if i have to
give up drinks with the girls on
saturdays and margarita mondays then
those are sacrifices right and so most
and i like putting both of those in
there because when you're writing copy
it's good to think about both sides
because you have to give up sleeping in
but you have to start
waking up early right so it just gives
you two sides to think about it from a
messaging perspective and so when we're
creating a product the ultimately
valuable product would be a product that
i didn't have to do anything for that
the moment i clicked purchase i knew it
was going to work and it happened
immediately
and so think about the difference
between let's say meditation right
meditation is the dream outcome is to
feel relaxed right perceive likelihood
of achievement meh time delay might take
us months of meditation to actually get
that kind of subjective well-being boost
right and then the effort and sacrifice
is i'm gonna have to sit cross-legged my
legs go numb i have to feel like an
idiot because i'm not staying focused um
i have to do this for 30 minutes every
single day to eventually yield the
results which is why
you know there's not a lot of huge
meditation distances right
flip side
what if i gave you a pill called xanax
you feel chill your perceived likelihood
is 100
the time delay is 15 minutes the effort
and sacrifice is you swallow some water
and that is why you have a multi-billion
dollar product
these are just the rules of value all
right and they don't care about who you
are or what you sell
these values sorry these pillars to
create value can apply so if you can
think about your own business and the
offers you have how can i increase the
dream outcome how can i increase the
perceived likelihood of achievement how
can i decrease the time delay for my
prospects and decrease what they have to
do in order to be successful
does that make sense
is that cool
is that a cool process for envisioning
value you can apply that framework
because once you see it you really can't
unsee it um and that's how i think
through any of the products that we're
ultimately going to sell on any of the
companies that we own all right and so
five six seven eight nine so scarcity
how to build that into your offers
urgency scarcity is a function of units
urgency is a function of time people
usually lock them together but they are
different
bonuses are one of the things you're
gonna offer in access of your of your
core offer what are the guarantees we're
going to offer to reverse the risk
there's four you have unconditional
conditional implied and anti-guarantees
all right there's lots of stuff that i
wish i could talk to you more about in
terms of creating offer and so what i
want to do is give you guys something
cool all right at acquisition.com i have
this entire course outlined um this book
is 99 cents you don't have to opt in for
it so i'm not trying to build my list or
anything like that i just want you guys
to have this stuff so you can just win
all right i really have nothing to sell
you which is why that's the tagline on
my youtube channel um i just want more
people to win all right so if you if you
want a deep dive on each of these it
comes with uh checklists and swipe files
and downloads it's all free you don't
have to give me anything um and then if
you like the digital version uh the
kindle's 99 cents so hopefully anywhere
you are in the world
no matter what the economic climate is
you can scrounge up 99 cents uh to get
the you know to get all the stuff all
right so um it's all free my gift to you
like i said books there and if you like
any of this type of stuff i have a
youtube channel you can follow me on um
and i have an instagram account all
right so if you if you like this type of
stuff um
i hope you do and uh as a side note if
you are a company that's an e-learning
or brick-and-mortar chain looking to
scale we invest in companies that are at
one to ten ish million that are trying
to get to 10 to 50 million and beyond so
that's kind of what we do so appreciate
you guys thank you
for your attention i hope you feel like
you got a good return on it and have at
least a few frameworks that you can
apply to increase the effectiveness of
your offers and ultimately get more
people to opt in
more people to convert by percentage at
higher prices and ultimately provide far
more value than anyone else in your
markets